they call this florida's space coast the
stretch of beaches and waterways from
which history can be glimpsed for the
second time in a week though what's
known as the scrub exodus
this is artemis launch control
the launch director waved off today's uh
attempt
at launching at approximately 11 17 a.m
eastern time launch team
ran into a liquid hydrogen leak while
loading propellant into the core stage
of the space launch system rocket
it was a different problem than the one
which caused monday's cancellation but
nasa's chief says they won't be rushed
we'll go when it's ready
we don't uh go until then and especially
now
on a test flight because we're going to
stress this and test it
and test that heat shield
and make sure it's right before we put
four humans up on the top of it
and there while out of direct
communication it's been 50 years since
man last walked on the moon this time
nasa plans to send a woman and a person
of colour too the first crewed mission
of artemis is scheduled for 2025.
it's it's been a very very long time
since we've been there
i do think it's something we need to
explore more
and
see what is out there what we are
capable of
do you think that nasa can can fix this
problem and get this rocket to the moon
i definitely think they can they've done
it before so
they could do it again
i don't know if i'm gonna come back for
the third one
but
yeah this is one's a little bit
disappointing but i took
i took lemons and made lemonade
that's all i could do
artemis has already cost over 40 billion
dollars but in a country which is
increasingly divided it is providing a
rare source of unification and a sense
of excitement america entering a new era
of space exploration
there's patience too even as the delays
are mounting here more than most places
they appreciate that this is quite
literally rocket science and it's an
unpredictable business martha kellner
sky news on cape canaveral